das ist schon erschütternd was da zum
teil einfach auch nicht inhalt zutritt
zum ausdruck kommt dass meine auch
dieses lied wenn ich das aus dem
ironischen lustigen rausnehmen und sage
das ist ja eigentlich fürchterlich wenn
das eigentlich jetzt das angebot ist das
ist unsere diskussion ich bin heute
etwas in berlin rumgelaufen ist bei den
andern parteien nicht besser da sehe ich
ein plakat der fdp christian lindner
drauf da steht drauf noch nie gab es
mehr zu tun er steht mit dem dann muss
ich sagen
das macht nach trümmerfrau also noch 45
gab es in deutschland mehr zeit und in
meiner ehre und ist das zweite lindner
müssen die schweiz gekommen war in
dieser woche in die schweiz machte
wahlkampf für die gefühl millionen
deutschen die in der schweiz sind und
dort abstimmen können quasi wie ein
erdogan in deutschland kommt ländern in
die schweiz und die deutschen rocker zu
machen
das ist blanker erdogan der deutschen
innenpolitik
wahlkampf technik dem ausland was macht
das wird ja bei erdogan nicht gut wenn
man freunde wir haben wir sprechen über
die grünen und christian lindner das hat
er nicht verdient also deshalb deshalb
dagegen nicht verdient
[Musik]